I'm not sure I could do any of the leg
stuff right now I just got my ass flip
it was like exerting my muscles in a way
like they've never done before this is
so much harder than any of the workouts
I've been doing the past few weeks but
that Pete sit down eat a salad hi my
name is angel and for the next seven
days we're gonna be training like prison
inmates hi my name is Vivian we've been
high school I just kind of do a random
workouts here and there I don't really
have a plan or routine I just kind of
try to be active and fit for me I'm
really scared about this because as far
as the workout plan that I'm currently
on there is no workout plan okay I have
not been you at the gym if I'm being
completely honest and I really am
looking for something that's gonna get
me motivated to go out and do it again I
want to be slim thick you know I want to
have the lung like I want some like
Michelle Obama arms some of the room on
the arm you know sometimes there's a
little bit of this thing making the
salient has a booty that is just like
next-level and I'm trying to be on her
level I want to look back at it like
sup everybody my name is Klaus Martin
I'm the CEO of Cambodia what we do is
hire people coming up with a prison
system to teach fitness classes and it's
all calisthenics
no equipment our body weight exercises
that I created from my personal
experience while I was incarcerated I
served a total of six years in prison
and when I went into prison doctors told
me my cholesterol levels and my blood
pressure was through the roof and that I
could try to die of a heart attack
within five years so that lent me up to
start exercising will be right in my
prison cell and I managed to lose over
70 pounds of six months we're doing
combo you live stream workouts you
basically will get a zoom link you'll
see everybody on the screen ten me and
you screen
try to keep up I'm gonna be watching you
with the video on so don't try to cheat
I wouldn't cheat I wouldn't she I'm
really gonna try and go like four hard
for the seven days we keep the bar super
high and you just try to keep up with us
I'm super high this might be the biggest
physical challenge I've ever had to do
how would you say are different training
routines are gonna be or are we gonna
need to be the same stuff you saw
there's nothing Taylor I don't keep it
weak Oh
how long are is the whole workout you'll
do 40 minutes of basically working out
sometime we'll go a little bit longer
but then we are gonna stretch well I
cannot look like that do see because
that's all I really want other this I
lose 40 pounds and get one week you know
cost my expectations are high I'm
supposed to come up you know summer 2020
is here you really want to like see
results quicker I mean my diet is a huge
thing but that Pizza down eat a salad
you're gonna need a little bit of carbs
make sure you hydrate a lot all right so
we're gonna get this hop in I can't wait
happy yep
and if you don't receive that big of the
difference in body within a week if you
see it mentally difference I'm gonna get
focus and I'm gonna motivate you to take
your body to the next level day one and
I am feeling really motivated but I'm
really scared it's not fit for day one
because fashion motivate okay gently are
you ready
[Music]
okay so the workout is still going on I
had to take a stop just because one I'm
dying and - I like completely I pulled
my leg it hurts to like move it at all
like I'm literally limping right now I'm
gonna hop back in I'm gonna try and push
forward for the rest of it but I'm not
sure I could do any of the leg stuff
right now see there that's where I
became deceased two minutes ago this is
actually my spirit rising up from the
wave to let you all know that I just got
my ass whooped
I got disappointing news I didn't
actually make it through the first
workout I couldn't keep up I couldn't do
basically anything like anything on the
ground was like so extraneous like it
was like exerting my muscles in a way
like they've never done before I think
my fitness goals for this week are
changing because stamina is definitely
necessary to get through these workouts
I mean honestly I thought we would get
more breaks in between I can do all the
moves but being able to have the
endurance to keep going that's what I
need to work on the most
I was so tired I was so sore
everything was so sore that I almost
couldn't get through the workout this
was so much harder than any of the
workouts I've been doing for the past
few weeks or even months because I don't
normally push myself like this we're at
the end of day two and I did it I
actually completed the entire workout
probably not to the level of everyone
else but I'm feeling so much better
today I'm not gonna give up as I said
like I'm so much better today than I was
yesterday and that's like what the
mentality I like to keep going I'm gonna
push through it five more days we got
this
we're sorry I don't even know I didn't
get the desired and I'm sweaty day three
post-workout I'm trying to keep my
spirits up today but it's been really
hard cuz like I don't know just reading
like all the headlines and stuff like
that
obviously prisoners are not able to
leave and like this whole Cove it 19
thing is happening and it's like really
disheartening especially because most of
that insane most but like a lot of the
people in jail like are incarcerated for
like nonviolent crimes by smoking
marijuana and stuff like that meanwhile
weed and like dispensaries are
considered an essential business during
this time that correlation doesn't make
sense to me it just has me like very in
thought right now
hopefully tomorrow is a better day and
my spirit goes back up
[Music]
we are mid-workout he's giving us like a
teeny tiny little break about a little
break I mean like about 1/32 he is he's
yelling and I New York accent and
obviously makes me miss my mom you
managed do like a hundred burpees today
I didn't do a hundred burpees because I
can't keep up with this man where any of
the men who worked there or the women or
anybody viv is actually doing the
hundred burpees shout out to her it'll
be a new day tomorrow I'm really excited
to keep going we only got three days
left or beyond the halfway mark I'm so
excited
y'all your girl is feeling the result of
being on day five of this challenge I
woke up like a rocket ship I just zoomed
out of bed this morning and it's because
I had so much energy I feel good there's
no more lightheadedness I'm not dizzy I
can get through it I feel so much
stronger a lot of the movements we did
today our movements we've done over the
course of the five days and now I know
what I'm doing and I feel more confident
in that I also feel like my body is more
comfortable being pushed that way which
it wasn't the first few days it is end
of day five and I am so sore right now
like my legs and my arms are so beat up
from this process I'm so excited for
this to be ending I don't know I might
be in love with mark shout out to him
for being beautiful I don't know what it
is about mark but every time he's there
is just so much easier to work out
I feel so much more energetic I'm more
motivated I feel really positive even
though like it's really painful the
workouts have been a big stress reliever
for me I feel like I've been able to
work out some of my frustrations but
life right now in the workouts which is
awesome I've never done so many part
beads in my freakin life who knew that
something so simple as laying out and
then popping back up could like really
make you contemplate your whole life I
hate puppies hey everyone it's after the
workout exercise like each time we do it
just becomes so much less dreadful than
the last time I think it's just cuz like
our bodies are getting used to it
feeling good about it
I'm feeling really motivated to finish
this last day I'm honestly excited about
it this is it this is the last day of
the challenge I am feeling amazing this
morning I got up real early for this
[Music]
I've never consistently worked out at
this high intensity seven days in a row
in the middle of the workout and then
it's okay
I'm dying this one's harder than every
other one but I like keep doing it
we did it we did it we did it we did it
I'm just really happy that we got to do
this this was so much fun
I feel very motivated maybe I didn't
lose like 30 pounds or something like
that in like a week but like I feel like
my mindset is completely different right
now I also feel like I can do anything
because the way I pushed myself over
these seven days I've never pushed
myself like that in my entire life yo so
we just get a whole week of working out
how y'all feeling appreciate job Jordan
I know y'all right now but let me know
what's up
I feel stronger I feel healthier I feel
more motivated to get through this
quarantine like a champ I feel like I
can take down any linebacker that is out
there and that's that first day was
running away from me John got me all
kinds of messed up saying I wasn't
really running away I was more limping
away you really damaged me in a way that
no man has ever done that like
emotionally you were you came out with
like a six-pack yeah the thing for me is
this wasn't a physical challenge it was
a mental challenge the entire way
through because after a while I realized
I know all these movements I can do them
by to have no brains no breaks in
between like my mind just had to really
sit and think like can we do this I'm
gonna get through it does feel like a
sense of freedom just like losing your
mind
and losing control of everything and you
just having somebody tell you what to do
and you just keep going and you don't
even think and you just do and then you
have a whole hour go by and you're like
wow I feel great that I did something I
accomplished something but I also got my
mind out of all the chaos that was going
around us still going around this well
thank you so much something magical
[Music]